pour gabriel la rentrée scolaire va se
faire sous les couleurs françaises
cet étudiant brésilien de 19 ans a
choisi la france et plus
particulièrement l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
pour son échange à l'étranger choisi la
france parce que la france est une vraie
puissance cantons actuels en sciences
humaines
cette renommée intellectuelle lu vs qu
l'entretien à travers plus de 200
formations réunies sur cinq campus
l'année 2010 est signe même son grand
retour au classement de shanghaï
puisqu'elle est élevée au 40e rang
mondial en sciences de la terre des
méthodes d'enseignement qui paie mais
pas toujours évidente à intégrer
l'amphithéâtre c'est une chose nouvelle
brazès est dans les salles plus petit
avec des cours plus petits c'est une
nouvelle expérience aussi bas les
lectures parce que ici on a en y délivre
le président lee de différents chapitres
de beaucoup de livres on n'a ni parents
ni frontières pour accompagner les
étudiants une semaine d'intégration est
organisée au programme animations et
rencontres comme le language teaching
ils ont ainsi l'occasion de nouer des
liens avec leurs homologues français
même si aujourd'hui le véhicule ne peut
donner suite à tous les dossiers de
candidature ils sont nombreux chaque
année à rejoindre les bancs de
l'université à lui vs qu on a environ
10% des étudiants
étrange et donc ça représente entre 1800
et 2000 étudiants à l'année enfin selon
les années et puis on a aussi les
étudiants qui viennent un programme des
changes comme erasmus par exemple est
donc là ça représente entre 100 et 150
étudiants à l'année association sportive
littéraires musicales et bien d'autres
les nouveaux arrivants sont entre de
bonnes mains